hey guys my name is Jess it is the 21st
of February and you're watching games
but news hit that subscribe button to
get one of these every single day when
Aniyah dollars
well the Nintendo switch wasn't exactly
swimming in launch titles and now it has
one less The Binding of Isaac after
birth Plus has been delayed until an
unspecified date developer Nicolas
confirmed the news in a blog post where
they didn't give a reason for the delay
but said they couldn't inform fans
sooner due to quote issues way beyond
our control
on the upside the company announced that
Binding of Isaac physical switch version
will come with a reversible cover a
twenty page instructional manual and a
limited edition sticker sheet which I
maintain do not get less cool as you get
hold up after birth plus is an expansion
to the base binding of issac game the
DLC pack launched last month on PC and
is also coming to ps4 and Xbox one in
related Nintendo switch news go ahead
and grab your Nintendo switch user ID at
accounts dot Nintendo calm before
someone NAB's your suite handle and you
have to put a one at the end
next up the day one patch for horizon
zero dawn has been details fortunately
it's not going to take forever to
install as the update only comes in at
around two hundred and fifty megabytes
the patch includes performance based
improvements on ps4 Pro and higher
visual fidelity for both 4k and 1080p
stats according to patch notes posted by
PlayStation Universe develop a gorilla
said horizon zero dawn will receive a
small Daisy patch that will build upon
PlayStation 4 per support adding a
performance mode which will favour
smoother frame rates while delivering
higher visual fidelity in the 1080p mode
this mode is available for both 4k and
1080p display horizon zero dawn is out
on February 28th in North America and
March 1 in Europe so you can stick it to
all those smug games ur knows who got
their copies before you then now I gotta
go home and play horizons finally Xbox
boss Phil Spencer has answered a bunch
of illuminating fan questions and
Spencer told one fan good games shipping
are positive for industry calling out
games like Forza horizon 3 The Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild Civ 6 overwatch
and horizon zero dawn he added that
gamers should celebrate these titles no
matter what platform they're playing on
Spencer added Xbox is having a good
generation and the Xbox 1s has been
strong since it came out in August of
2016
he tweeted can always improve but proud
of where we are that is everything I got
for you today do head to GameSpot for
stories on Rainbow six siege and The
Legend of Zelda breath of the world and
I'll see you tomorrow